so Thomas we're here to discuss whether
ed I can recover a super palate what do
you think I think it depends what you
consider a superpower is it is a
superpower a country that has military
strength economic strength visit a
country that has intellectual strength
and if you look at all these various
measures I think that India already is a
superpower in quite a few disrespect
what do you think is most valid measures
question well I guess in many ways the
very idea of the superpower is a very
western ocean somewhere like that we've
received almost as part of the history
of the 20th century one that was
dominated by two Western powers USSR and
USA he juxtaposes against one another I
guess the question for me is not so much
whether India will be a superpower of
whether it can define a different type
of paradigm within which it sees itself
as a cute part of the world's structure
a key part of the world's meeting
countries who every way that you carried
on is divine yeah and I think that in
some ways it already is a superpower
again another aspect of this is the till
these come home at this meeting is the
power of the Indian diaspora Indians
throughout the world and I keep in
meeting again to come back to India from
very vibrant communities overseas and
they really have this super grounder
exists is really a case of India itself
getting things together is that Martin
is or or maybe a maybe a breakfast
should maybe a part of what needs to be
like maybe was a different kind of label
so if you don't use the term super
powering what kind of ways they're
describing India maybe something that
comes out of this garage or something
along those lines he really is heritage
describe what a get rich the table in
the same way that India do not
participate the dynamic between the USA
vs s are looking at the non-aligned are
they raising you could define itself
differently but using the criteria that
you talked about earlier which are
metrics of a country not reading them on
the world stage economy military social
engagement increasing social inclusion
India double does not all
so I think what we're seeing is actually
given its what does that mean in terms
of its way of engaging what kind of
models are simply forward for itself I
donut in other words India is definitely
a superpower we question the valley that
notion of what a superpower is